this is where ondrea's colic is in his
element his team's as the German chef
has got great taste not just in food but
also a music
yeah I like having music on it relaxes
me even if it's hard rock havoc music on
in the background helps me focus on my
work in 2015 andreas became head chef in
frankfurt sloth lure restaurant he
earned his first michelin star in 2005
he started getting great reviews from
food critics and now he's been named
germany's chef of the year his phone
hardly seems to stop bringing these days
the restaurants wine suppliers even stop
by to congratulate him he tries to stay
cool despite all the praise
with up over that there's a certain
amount of pressure but I create that
pressure myself like I've always done so
external pressure doesn't affect me that
much I think I have a sense for the
appropriate amount of pressure in the
mouth with knew that his Andreas has
helped boost the image of vegetables as
a gourmet food every morning he heads to
the wholesaler to collect fresh produce
he's obsessed with quality in 2014 he
was among the first star chefs to offer
a vegan gourmet menu a quarter of his
patrons opted for it his autumnal menu
includes a dish with fennel carrots and
turnips in warm carrot sauce with orange
oil green foam gerbil fermented yuzu and
crunchy quinoa is he challenging
traditional gourmet cuisine volim
unmentioned why should people on a
different diet be excluded from
top-quality cuisine I challenge myself
to deliver high quality vegan food it
takes more effort and it's
time-consuming but it's doable when this
movie all song is money I'll find us
aside in disease I was it moving
the outdoors plays an important role in
croelick's life his favorite way of
winding down is to head to Norway's
fjords but he's so busy that he usually
doesn't make it further than the local
park
he finds being out in nature both
relaxing and inspiring croelick grew up
in eastern Germany he reckons he
developed his flair for flavors as a
child spending time outdoors
we grew a lot of fruit vegetables we had
big gardens with virtually everything
the season had to offer it was a lot of
work but I'm convinced that it shaped my
sense of taste because you were always
getting a natural taste we didn't have
exotic herbs or spices so vegetables had
to stand out on the road and Reyes is
also considered an expert on fish he
takes great care with its preparation in
his free time he's also a passionate
fisherman Margo the gaana when it comes
to freshwater fish I especially like
arctic char it's very juicy and melts in
your mouth ones it then you can serve it
raw or just cook it very lightly it'll
not be God through Biden his Lafleur
restaurant is located in downtown
Frankfort the decor is simple and
elegant in the atmosphere relaxing a
complete contrast to the kitchen where
there's a buzz of activity two blaring
rock music
andreas opts for local produce this
fall's menu includes saddle of venison
it's fried pink with a spicy brioche red
cabbage cranberries marinated black
chanterelles turnip and marinated black
chanterelle cream and a venison bouillon
served with ravioli filled with organic
goose liver and braised venison English
more dovish other than ondrea's colak
germany's chef of the year unlikely to
rest on his laurels